you
my name is amar and I lead project
fiddle here at Microsoft Research my
colleagues and I are working on speeding
up distributed machine learning jobs our
emphasis has been on distributed deep
learning DNN models are expensive to
train not just in the amount of
resources they consume but also in the
amount of time they take to train these
DNN models and so the motivation for
these systems you know we have this new
generation of big data systems in this
generation of AI we have applications
such as we have tasks such as image
recognition classification translation
and speech to text and text-to-speech
conversion and there have been various
solutions that have been proposed over
the years so I think the first
generation of solutions like this belief
and project Adam looked at using
commodity computers to solve some of
these problems using DNS and the next
generation of systems like tensorflow
and Microsoft CNT came were
generalizations that you know let the
program or specify how to code up these
DNS and solve many of these tasks as
opposed to you know point solutions for
specific tasks but the key factor that
still remains as DNN training is
extremely time and resource consuming
and so jobs training jobs last days to
multiple weeks at times and there's this
constant cycle of train validate repeat
which you know blows up the training
time effectively
one of the one of the most important
things in this work is naively
paralyzing this work can actually be
detrimental because what really matters
at the end of the day is the quality of
work our time to reach a certain
accuracy and so the problem that we're
trying to solve here is we've set an
ambitious goal for ourselves we'd like
to perform 100x more efficient training
intuitively what this means is if you
have a model that takes an entire day to
Train
we'd like to train this model in 15
minutes over your coffee break and the
approach we take in project fiddle is
the cut across the system stack so you
know we look at the end we look at
training the bigger picture of training
from a single GPU all the way up to
multi-gpu multi machine clusters across
the system stack so we look at the
memory subsystem we look at how to
structure computation across these
different computational units we look at
the communication infrastructure so you
know it's speeding up communication
which is inherent in this workload and
then finally all the way up the stack
you know I've been talking about these
these innovations that help a single job
but we look at sort of multiple jobs all
using the same cluster running in this
multi-tenant clustered environment and
we're looking at techniques to make
fault tolerant elastic training work on
these clusters let me take a very
specific example you know to do to keep
you grounded in in example so one of the
projects just looks at how much more can
we do on a single GPU so before you ask
for your second GPU we'd like to make
sure that you're maxing out the
capabilities of a single GPU so let's
move here where I explained just the
first thing to note here is what I'm
showing you here is memory is a
bottleneck for even single GPU training
so sorted on this x-axis we've sorted
different DN ends for image
classification effectively saw
over time and you'll note that the
memory consumed by these different DNA's
over time increases we further dug
deeper and you know we want to find out
what in there is consuming memory and
the stuff that's marked in red that's
highlighted in red are the heavy hitters
and those are the feature maps that are
stored and needed for backward
computation during BNN training so the
to explain this in sort of an abstract
way here's the representation of a DNN
layer you can think of any layer taking
as input X outputting some feature map Y
and then in its backward pass it's going
to take some output gradient D by an
output sort of this gradient DX and DX
is a function of X Y and dy it could be
a function of X Y and dy and so to
compute D X now we need to actually
store x and y so this is sort of the
abstract view of what a layer does if we
unroll this over time this is the same
representation of that we've unrolled it
over time a lie here takes as input X
and outputs Y and much later in its
backward pass takes as input dy and
outputs DX and so you know if you just
look at the lifetime of this data
structure X its first generated here and
then you know used here and discarded
here but we know better
X is actually just used in this time
slot not used you know in this long gap
and then used again here during the
backward pass of a lie and so now we
have an opportunity here to take this
data structure and code it and hopefully
have a succinct representation of X in
this in this long time gap relinquish
all the memory that X was consuming and
then decode that encoded representation
into a full-fledged representation again
when we need to do backward computation
so just takes in you know the original
computation graph for a particular task
and statically for every data structure
augments this computational graph to
have these encode decode edges and our
memory manager effectively manages all
these memory regions
I was hand waving here when I talked
about encode and decode functions but
specifically we have a bunch of
techniques both lossless and lossy
techniques that are you know used for
these encode and decode functions and
the higher order bit here is using these
using gist for these networks we can get
up to a 2x compression ratio encode
decode of course is not free we you know
for these different networks there's a
minimal overhead of one to seven percent
that we pay for the same mini-bat size
but the beauty of gist is we can enable
larger mini batch sizes to be loaded and
so you know with larger many batch sizes
will have faster training so this was
gist which is one extreme of the
spectrum making a single GPU do more
effectively let me take you to this
other extreme which is multi machine
training so parallel programming is hard
in general and you know I want to
showcase why it's harder paralyzing DNN
training so for that let's move on to
this particular terminal I'm gonna skip
ahead a couple of slides to get to slide
where I talk about parallel training
lines so let me talk about pipe dream
which you know is a new way to
parallelize DNN computation so the the
most important thing to note here is
ninth paralyzation can hurt the NN
training because if you naively paralyze
something you might actually be
increasing the total time for training
because total time of training depends
on two things
time for epoch and the number of epochs
for a given accuracy and while you might
decrease the time per epoch you might be
increasing the number of epochs
effectively
one of the predominant ways of
paralyzing DNS is this thing called data
parallel training where you run multiple
replicas and these replicas communicate
with each other every so often and if
you aggregate in all the times for
compute and communication stalls you
notice this pattern where there is a
bunch of time you're spending just
communicating and so in that the problem
there of course is that of hardware
efficiency you're waiting for
communication to occur and you're not
doing any compute this you know this is
including optimizations like weight free
big back propagation but try to set a
pipeline communication and computation
so this was a fake graph let me show you
a real graph here's different networks
image classification rnns that we tried
out and one thing that you'll notice is
as you increase the number of workers
let's just consider one of those demons
for a given GPU setting
let's take K 80s for example you'll
notice that the amount of time that's
taken in communication of you know to
communicate these parameters for
parameter exchange is going up so we're
plotting communication overhead as a
percentage of total time but what's
worse is as you start using faster
compute so if you go from key 80s to be
100's your computer is going much faster
but the amount you're communicating is
still the same and so the communication
overhead
shoots up dramatically the other
approach that's used for parallel
training is this thing called model
parallelism where you know you take a
model and split it up across set of
different GPUs and so this is most
commonly used to work around memory
limitations if you can't load an entire
model onto one GPU so this is great and
enables you to at least
train this model but there are two sort
of major challenges one it's extremely
hard for the programmer to figure out
where to split this model these splits
will vary not just based on the DNN
that's being trained but also will vary
based on the deployment
in question and the second is that of
low hard sort of hardware efficiency so
you'll notice in this figure that only
one GPU effectively is active at any
given point in time and all the other
GPUs are sitting idle because of the
nature of this computation to do
backward work at Machine one for
mini-batch one it has to wait for you
know the work to go through all the
other machines and come back to it so
the idea we have in pipe dream is to you
know we're sort of good in take a real
look at model parallelism but not for
memory limitations but instead for
throughput and we're going to use this
idea of pipelining so we're going to you
know admit more number of jobs into the
pipeline at the same time we'd like to
have the programmer not have to specify
how to parallelize this workload and so
we have we have a tool that
automatically figures out what the right
parallelization scheme is and then a
runtime that executes this in the
programmer is not involved in this in
this process at all and so the way this
is done is I'm just gonna skip to the
slide that talks about this we take a
DNN run run it through our profiler and
this run is just on you know one of the
GPUs it doesn't have to run on all the
GPUs that you're going to run this on
and it spits out the profile of per
layer times as well as how much data is
communicated between layers and based on
this information and given the number of
machines that you want to run this on
our optimizer can spit out a
configuration for paralyzation and so
you know pipedream combines model
parallelism data parallelism and
pipelining and the speed ups that we
observe because of these combined
pipelining is significant we get up to
5x speed-up for various tasks that we've
tried this out for be it image
classification or RN ends for example
sequence to sequence models that do
video to text transcription so to wrap
things up so in project fiddle we are
building we're doing systems research to
speed up BNN training and we take a
broader view of training from single
GPUs to you know multiple GPU multiple
machine setup and we cut across the
system stack from the memory subsystem
to how to structure computation
automatically to communication
you know that's inherent in this in this
training paradigm all the way up to you
know fault tolerant elastic training on
shared multi telling clusters thanks
you